ما هو الوباء وكيف نعرف أنه عندما نكون في وسط حالة جيدة ، يكون الوباء عندما يكون لديك مرض معد ينتقل باستمرار ومستمر من شخص لآخر عبر مجموعة واسعة من المناطق والبلدان والمناطق في الكرة الأرضية ، على سبيل المثال في الصين ، إنه وباء لأنه يتركز في الصين ، ولكن بمجرد أن تبدأ في الوصول إلى بلدان أخرى لديك فيها قابلية انتقال مستدامة ، فأنت حقًا تمتلك مقومات جائحة Pam ، مما يعني أنه يتم توزيعه على نطاق واسع ، هل لدينا ذلك في أيدينا الآن أعتقد أن مايكل أننا على شفا ذلك بوضوح واسمحوا لي أن أشرح بإيجاز السبب لأن مصيرنا سيتم تحديده من خلال قدرة البلدان خارج الصين التي لديها حالات متعلقة بالسفر والآن بدأوا في تطوير انتقال مستمر من شخص لآخر ، لذا لا يقتصر الأمر في الوقت الحالي على الحالات المتعلقة بالسفر ، لذلك عندما تحصل على دول مثل اليابان وكوريا الجنوبية لديها هذه الحالات  أن
شخصًا لآخر دون أي
قدرة حقيقية على الإشارة إلى
مصدره ، فهذه هي ما يصنع الوباء
، وإذا كان لديك عدة دول من
هذا القبيل ، فسيكون الحصان خارج
الحظيرة وسيكون من الصعب جدًا
منع المزيد  حالات من المجيء إلى هنا
لبلدنا